[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは
沖縄から来ました
糸数と申します
私の友達はこういう場で私が話すとアホが
バレるって言うんですけれどもその私です
が今日は
背伸びをせずに
等身大の自分を皆さんと一緒にこの時間で
分かち合いたいと思いますよろしくお願い
します
私は現在50歳です
意外と若く見られるんですけどいかがです
かありがとうございます
矯正したみたいですけどはい私がどうして
年齢の話をするかというと出身の沖縄に
関係があります今年は沖縄は
復帰50周年を迎えました
私は
沖縄が日本に復帰した年に生まれました
知らない方もいるかもしれないのでお伝え
すると
沖縄戦後27年間アメリカの統治下にあり
ました
そして私の生まれた1972年に日本に
復帰しました
地元では私と同じ年に生まれた1972年
の子どもたちを
復帰後って呼んで親しみを込めています
私の名前
未来の希望と書きますが両親が私の時代に
沖縄から基地がなくなって平和な島になっ
ていることを
願って名付けたものです
ですが
父はまだ
存在し続けています
私は
那覇で生まれ育ちました
自分で言うのもなんですがエリート
街道を歩いてきました
高校は地元の進学校で英語が大好きだった
ので1年間アメリカのニューハンプシャー
州に
留学しました
英語も身につきましたが体の肉も身につき
ました
食欲も旺盛で帰ってからも食後にトースト
を食べようとして
父に叱られました
高校卒業して早稲田大学に入学しサークル
活動に明け暮れ東京ウォーカーを片手に
食べ放題巡りをしました
武勇伝は
寿司51巻を
握り寿司ですね51巻を気持ちよく完食し
たことです
隣にいる男子はギブアップしてましただ
から友達は私に元気って聞くよりもみき
ちゃん食ってるって言ってました
それぐらい食べることが好きです
私は大学を卒業する前に2年ほど中退をし
てクリスチャンでありましたがその
ボランティア活動に専念するために
いったん学校を離れましたそして2年後に
副学をして
沖縄の一流企業に就職して25年経ってい
ます
会社でもよく食べると評判で
沖縄そばをよく食べに行ってが連れて行っ
てくれた上司がいますしまた初対面の先輩
の弁当を残す弁当をもらったりとかして
結構
印象に残った新入社員だったかもしれませ
ん
私の現在の仕事は
接客業です
お電話を通じてお客様の苦情やそれからご
要望を聞くときにやりがいを感じています
職場にも大変恵まれました私はそんな
ライフスタイルでサラリーマン人生を送っ
ていますが今現在数々の活動をさせて
いただいてます
NPO法人の代表理事それから
子どもやまちづくりに関わる
団体の
財団法人やそこの理事やそして表現
伊那市役所での役所の会議に出席したり
また
健康オタクなのでアーユルヴェーダの勉強
とかそれから首里城が燃えた時には
危機管理を感じて私の方で防災士の資格を
取ろうと思ってつい最近防災士にもなり
ました
私は本当によく食べますけれども
即行動の人物です
あまり物事をよく考えずに動くものです
から周りがいつも呆れています
もう家族や友達も
呆れたを通り越し諦めた感じですね実は私
は
好奇心が旺盛で本当にいろんなことに
取り組むんですが
去年今年ですいません今年選挙にも出まし
た
座右の銘は自分が動けば周りも動くです
幸せ体質というふうに私は自分を呼んで
いるんですが自分の
身の回りに起こる一見不幸だったり不運
だったりすることを自分なりに意味の解釈
をしてそれを学びに変えるという得意技が
あります
そして
好奇心旺盛とも言いましたが自由奔放なの
でこういう私を見て一人っ子ですか
独身ですかと聞かれますけれども私は三
姉妹の長女ですそして
夫1人と20歳になる娘と16歳の息子と
猫2匹と暮らしています
こんな私をよくサポートしてくれる家族に
本当に心から感謝しています
では私がこれまでやってきたこれも今も
やってますけども3つの活動についてお
伝えしたいと思います
20年ほど前に
那覇の街で私は保育サービス講習会という
のを受けました
それは地域のお母さんたちが地域の子ども
たちを預かるというファミリーサポート
センターの立ち上げをある団体でしました
この団体というのが保育施設に那覇ですが
地域のお母さんたち先輩たちとともに
活動させてもらっています
当時私はお腹に長女がいました
妊娠中の私でしたので
子育ても1からスタートそしてこの団体も
スタート1からスタートでした
先輩お母さんたちにとってもお世話になり
ながらこの団体を立ち上げる楽しさを知り
ました
一緒の志で動くそして年齢も関係なく
その活動の楽しさを知り私は本当に本当に
このNPOの活動が
楽しくて
仕方なくて5つほど
立ち上げております
そのきっかけは実は保育とか
子育てに全く関係のない会社の上司の一言
でした
彼は私に
社内保育所を作ってみないかと持ちかけた
一人です
そしてまた彼は
サラリーマンで終わるなよやりたいことは
やったらいいそうやって後押しをくれた人
一人です
振り返ってみればこの彼の一言は大きかっ
たなと今思っています
そのような上司がいましたが彼はいつも
夢について語ったりそして実現していまし
たそして私もそのそばにいてワクワク
ドキドキしながら
刺激をもらっていました
そんな大人が身近にいたら
子どもたちはどう感じるでしょうかきっと
大人になることが
楽しくて
待ちきれなくて楽しくてそんな子供たちに
育つんじゃないでしょうか
こんな子供たちがいたら今の世の中は少し
変わっているかもしれません
そのような夢を持つ子どもたち
それを希望として持っていますがでも実際
夢を見ることが
困難な難しい子供たちも存在します
皆さんは18歳で
住んでいる家を出て戻ることが許されない
そして頼る人がいない
そんな時もし困ったらどうしますか
虐待や
貧困で親と暮らせない
子どもたちその子たちは児童養護施設や
里親家庭ファミリーホームで生活を送り
ますそして高校生になるとその卒業と同時
に公的な支援を終え自立を余儀なくされ
ます
頼れる親や家族がいない
そして
困った時に誰に相談したらいいんでしょう
か
そういう人生を生きていく子どもたちの
困難を
想像できますでしょうか
2011年1月私は県内の児童養護施設に
行く機会がありましたそこで大学2年生の
男子学生と出会いました
彼はバイトもして
奨学金も貯めて一生懸命勉学に
励んでいましたが次年度の3年生の時に
進学する資金がそこをついてしまいました
こんなに一生懸命頑張っても
施設の先生方も
経済的なサポートをすることができません
私は何不自由なく大学を出ました
就職もしました家族も持っています
幸せな人生を送っている
ですが一方で
手に入れたチャンスや進学を諦めなければ
いけない
この違いは一体何なのか
私は彼と出会った一人に大人として彼を
放っておけませんでしたあなたを応援し
たいと全力で思いましただから出会った時
に私は彼を卒業すると卒業させると心に
誓いました
そしてこの施設からの帰り道同行していた
友人が
沖縄のあるお母さんたちの話をしてくれ
ました
那覇の支離の地域で私利小学母の会という
のがあったんだよ
それは1960年代誰もが貧しくて学校に
行ける子たちが少なかった時
豆腐一丁のお金を支離のお母さんたちが
集めて
奨学金を作って
子どもたちを学校に出させたそういう記録
があるんだよ
私はその話を聞いてとても感動しました
この先輩お母さんたちの志を受け継ぎたい
現代版の豆腐一丁を丁寧に設定してこの
男子学生に
返すことのない必要のない
給付型の奨学金で仕送りをして
卒業までサポートしようと
活動を始めました
それが私の2番目の活動
虹の橋ファンドと言いますこの名前は娘と
つけました
虹のようにたくさんの可能性を持つ子ども
たちと
応援したい大人たちを結ぶそんな架け橋に
なりたい
給付型の奨学金で彼らの未来に投資をする
そういう意味を込めてこの名前をつけまし
た
おかげさまでサポーターさんは12年を
超えた今500名を超えサポートしてきた
子どもたちは100名を超えました
そして先ほどお伝えした学生も無事に大学
を卒業し
希望だった福祉の就職先につき
結婚して子供もいます
ですが彼のように順調な人生を送る子ども
たちは実は少ないんです
私たちがサポートした一人に
中退をした子がいました
彼は進路に迷いを迷いの気持ちを持ち
そして次年度2年生になる時の経済的な
負担がとても大きくて中退してしまいまし
た
なので
沖縄を離れて
季節労働として
働く選択を選びました
私はそれを知った時とっても悲しかった
そして悔しかったんです
どうして相談してくれなかったのもしかし
たらそれを相談してくれたら
卒業できたかもしれないのに
そういう気持ちがぐるぐる回っていました
でもそれもそのはず彼とは一度しか面談で
あったことがないです
そんな大人に
信頼したり
甘えたりすることは
到底できないわけです彼との関係性の溝を
私たち活動で埋めることはできませんでし
た
でもある時その季節労働先から年賀状が
届きました
そのメッセージにはこう書いてあります
僕も
虹の橋の糸数さんや皆さんに支援されてき
ました
今度は僕もいろんな人たちを応援できる
ように頑張ります
私はハッとしました
だって私は子供たちを卒業させることが
ゴールだと思っていた
だけど彼は
支援を受ける側から
支援する側へそんな気持ちで社会を生きて
いる
その気持ちが育ったことがどんなに
うれしかったか
私はこの彼の年賀状をずっと大切に持って
いますそしてそれを励みとして今この活動
を引き続きやっております
3つ目の活動についてお伝えしたいと思い
ます
皆さんはお気に入りのお気に入りの居場所
がありましたか子供の頃です
私にはありましたこれから紹介する
子ども
止まり子供図書館です
この図書館は特別なんです私の住んでいた
地域の
病院の先生が
病院の2階を開放して図書館として地域の
子どもたちに解放していました
お気に入りの漫画や
友達と遊んだり
季節ごとのイベントがありそして館長先生
これは奥さんになりますけれどもいつも
笑顔で私たちを迎えてくれました
私が子育て活動を20年ほど続けていると
お伝えしましたがその活動の合間に
ちょこちょここの思い出がよみがえりまし
たそしていつか私もこのような居場所を
子供たちに提供したいそう思って心の中で
温めていましたそしたら運が回ってきたん
です
2016年9月24日
虹の森文庫が開館しました
那覇市松川私の住んでる地域ですけれども
この開館が私の夢を叶えた一つのものに
なりました
きっかけは先ほど紹介した
活動2番目の活動のサポーターである三浦
さんという大阪の企業の社長さんでした彼
がわざわざ沖縄にやってきて私たちは会食
したのですがその時にもっと他に何かやる
ことはないですかと言われました
サポーターをしていただいているだけで
なく会社の皆さんにもこの活動を呼びかけ
て応援してくださっている方なので
いやいやもうそんなにたくさんやって
いただいての十分ですとお伝えしたんです
が周りのスタッフがみきさん
夢があるって言ったじゃないですかという
ので私は子供図書館の話をしました
そしたら三浦さんはぜひやりましょうって
すぐに答えてくださり帰ってから翌週
大きな寄付が口座に届いてました
それから3ヶ月のスピードでこの場所は
作られ
沖縄の大変お世話になってる
激安ホールディングさんという会社が内装
工事からそしてまたレッドカーペットの
開館式まで最初から最後までみんなを見て
くれました
三浦社長は三浦会長がその後も1000冊
を超える
訴訟
漫画を
寄付してくださり
仏心両面の応援を地域の皆さん知人友人の
方からいただきそして地域の肝っ玉かあ
ちゃんが館長を務めてくれています
現在は那覇市の女性と日本財団の女性を得
て
週6日土曜日を除いて
毎日ほぼ毎日オープンして
子どもたちに
子ども食堂やそしてまた学習支援の場とし
て活用してもらっています
この場が私が
幸せだった記憶と同じように
子どもたちがその記憶として
覚えてもらえたらと思っています
私がなぜフルタイムの仕事をしてこんなに
たくさんの活動しているのか
それはとっても
楽しいからです
むちゃくちゃ楽しいんですそしてそれが
生きがいです仕事そっちのけですと言っ
たら怒られますが
私がそのように
活動ができることそれは根幹に私が本当に
周りに今まで
恵まれてきたことがあります
家庭でも
職場でもそして
活動を通してもいつも周りに恵まれてき
ました
恵まれていることでできることがあると
思っています
当事者じゃなくてもその痛みや本当の
苦しみは分からなくても私たちが共感
できる力がありますそしてたくさんの発想
力を持って行動に移すことができます
私は日頃からアイデアが思い浮かべば
付箋紙に書いて
ペタペタペタとスマホの後ろに貼ってい
ます
いつも関心のアンテナを張り巡らせてい
生きがいとは何なんでしょうか皆さんが
生きがいを持って活動していることって
きっと関心があることだと思うんです
関心とは愛です
尊敬する先輩がこうおっしゃいました
愛には
説明も方法もいらないそこに行くと決める
だけ
そうすれば自ずと道が開けてくる
私はこれからもこれらの活動を通して
楽しく人と関わりたいと思いますまた来年
からはコミュニティFMで番組を持ちます
子どもと大人
マイノリティとマジョリティ
沖縄と本土
そのような人との出会いを結んで
架け橋としてこれからも人生を楽しんで
いきたいと思います
IHaven
私には夢がある
沖縄の子どもたちが生まれ育った環境に
関わらずなりたい自分になることを
大人が応援できる社会を目指したい
新しい一日が始まる時を
悲しさや苦しみで
迎える人の方に
そっと手を置く存在がある世の中にしたい
違いを認め合い歌ったり踊ったり
冗談の言い合える
心に遊びのある社会を
私にはそんな夢がある
[拍手]